what's up reject nation i'm greg what is
your name
my name is alyssa be crazy alyssa be
crazy follow her
on twitch and something else too that
you wanted me to mention a while ago and
i never did
what is it i haven't been on my personal
channel in a really long time
and i still every day i get comments
where are you it's been two years i
started a new channel on youtube it's
called
vibe vixen it was created on request
from my community to highlight new
artists music artists
and traditional artists every week we'll
post a new video i will
make sure to subscribe tomorrow
i know you'll do it we're going to watch
today from slapped ham
a fun spooky video i'm assuming the
creepiest discoveries
made by youtubers i'm sure we have a few
in our pocket let's see what's in store
alyssa assemble the headphones
how you doing i'm calling and this is
slapped ham from one youtuber who
discovered a great white shark in an
abandoned wildlife park
to another who found a disturbing
vampire doll in an ancient graveyard
just quickly before we get into these
fascinating stories remember to hit that
subscribe button for more awesome creepy
i already did you should too
i love the name it's so funny
in november 2018 youtuber lucky mc
made a truly creepy discovery while
exploring an abandoned wildlife park
how does that happen australia i don't
know the video begins with a camera
holder and a friend
entering a dilapidated wooden shack that
leads into a bizarre cave-like structure
he comments on the vile smell as they
pass several small
alcoves one of which contains an
overturned vending machine
while another holds an old table and
chairs the walls are littered with faded
pictures of australian animals
why the pair make their way down a long
dark tunnel before once again emerging
into sunlight
they pass an overgrown enclosure that
once housed some sort of animal
before entering another rundown
the structure appears to have been a
living area possibly designed for guests
to stay overnight while visiting the
park
right the camera holder peeks into a
half open fridge
it still contains jars of food a large
container of rancid milk sits on the
bottom shelf
the explorers continue to look around
the derelict building
the broken furniture littered across the
floor suggests that someone's been here
before
or is possibly still living inside yeah
no cautiously the pair move on
they approach a wall that looks as
though it's been ripped down revealing
what appears to be a secret storage
space
okay the two decide to enter the strange
room
becomes darker and darker the further
they go in
unable to see clearly the camera holder
pans a light around the room
he notices a large tank that appears to
be filled with some sort of dark liquid
unable to see inside the two explorers
make their way around to the opposite
side of the tank
suddenly the pair realized that they're
staring at the tail of a very large
creature
is it alive no it can't be heard
that is creepy ass as the camera holder
slowly pans the length of the tank
revealing the beast wow suddenly its
head
and huge teeth-filled mouth that's
horrible video went viral luke emc was
contacted by the previous side
who informed him that the giant creature
was in fact a five meter long great
white shark
it was moved to the tank after becoming
entangled in fishing nets and dying off
the coast of south australia
the dark liquid in the tank was actually
formaldehyde
oh so it was already dead okay i gotta
like
die there they're abandoning it that
makes me feel so much better about it
oh my god
[Music]
eyes are moving
some viewers suggested that the doll
might actually be possessed
it could contain the spirit of someone
buried in the graveyard
no the doll might be an evil idol
designed to summon a real vampire
well it was later revealed that the doll
was in fact the work of a sculptor
it made for a very creepy discovery of
course
something you wouldn't want to come
across while exploring a spooky old
i'm gonna have cemetery about that baby
that's so good exploring with josh made
a very creepy discovery in 2016.
in a cave in the gifford pinchot
national forest in washington
finds a young girl in a cave a cave is
the longest continuous lava tube in the
continental united states
okay and has long been a popular learn
something new today
the cave received its bizarre name in
1924 when the residents of the small
mining community became convinced that
apes were throwing rocks into the canyon
the rumor persisted until 1984 when an
elderly man came forward revealing that
it was in fact he and a friend that had
been throwing the rocks ah
the hoax as josh and several others make
their way towards the mouth of the cave
one of them can be heard saying oh god
this looks like something out of a
horror movie
with lanterns in hand the group slowly
head into the darkness
at one point the cave becomes so narrow
they're forced to crawl on their hands
and knees
the temperature begins to drop as icy
breath can be seen coming from the
mouths of the explorers
why would you keep going it seems too
small to continue
and the group contemplate returning back
to the surface
however just as they're about to turn
back they discover that the cave
actually starts to widen once again
now crawling on their stomachs the group
decides to press forward
suddenly they hear what sounds like
someone crying in the distance
scared they slowly head towards the
noise one of the group shines a
flashlight into the darkness
illuminating a young what oh my god
extraordinarily the girl had managed to
crawl her way into the depths of the
cave
all by herself without a flashlight
they soon discover that she doesn't
speak english motioning for her to
follow them
the group lead her back to the surface
where she's finally reunited with her
worried parents
wow they saved the little girl oh that
is crazy
that is nuts that's the kind of thing
that like
shows the moment several times it has to
have been like meant to happen you know
otherwise like
yeah kayak their way through rayleigh
bay in krabi thailand
the furry creatures can be seen
sheltering near a cave as they play some
sort of strange hypnotic melody or
unusual musical instruments how
cool amused kayakers look on in
disbelief as the beasts appear to
perform
just for them
when the video first surfaced it whipped
the internet into a friend
that can't be reviewed over what the
mysterious pictures actually were
some suggested aliens while others
thought they may have been some type of
reclusive cave dwelling animal
that was yet to be discovered wow it was
later revealed however that the
creatures were actually costumed actors
[Music]
and the bizarre sounds were created by
travelling vocalist tori reigns
even though it was staged the tourists
initially had no idea
and the dumbfounded looks that you can
see on their faces are quite
real imagine paddling
what a great prank and then stumbling
across this
[Music]
i would have been tripping out yeah
in august 2014 youtuber mr technical
difficult made a very
what is it always dolls in the video
with a group of friends
when the camera holder notices a strange
white box floating downstream
he convinces one of the men in shorts to
swim over to the other side
and retrieve it man in shorts box
appears to be a drinks cooler that's
been sealed with
tape to stop it from opening the man
removes one of the people that's how you
unleash a car
yeah man it's so messed up he
immediately jumps back after spotting
what he thinks is a small
child the camera holder then approaches
the box to get a closer
orchestrated by another group further
upstream it's still a very
unsettling find like i don't know that's
because
sometimes but discovering one in a box
floating down river
that's a whole new level of nightmare
that is so funny
but that is a prank that is so funny
youtuber who thinks he's found the lost
city of atlantis
remember to hit that subscribe button
and turn on channel notifications
that way you'll be completely up to date
with all our latest that's so eerie but
what a great way to mess with someone
you
tape it up it's so smart i would burn it
of course this video published on bryant
insight's youtube channel in 2018
not only claims that the lost city of
atlantis was real
but that its actual location has been
hiding in plain sight for thousands of
years
the video analyzes the descriptions of
atlantis found in the great philosopher
plato's dialogues
timaeus and critteaus the works claimed
to quote ceylon
an athenian lawmaker and poet who
traveled to egypt between 590 and 580 bc
who was believed to have translated
egyptian records of atlantis
using plato's words as a guide the video
suggests that the true location of
atlantis
is likely to be the richard structure in
mauritania
a country in northwest africa what
the structure sometimes referred to as
the eye of sahara
was originally thought to have been
created by an increase of pressure
caused by
underlying magma or even the impact of a
large meteorite
the video goes on to suggest that the
symmetrical circles of the eye of the
sahara
may have once been filled with water and
closely resembled the description given
by plato of the mysterious city
the video also compares several other
striking similarities between plato's
descriptions and the geographical
orientation of the eye
including a large mountainous region to
the north and
an inlet to the south that once possibly
flowed with water
if this theory does indeed turn out to
be true it will no doubt be one of the
greatest discoveries ever made by a
youtuber
investigate i want to see oh my god
i'm going to follow that that's
incredible
i've just got to say like you love what
we do then consider supporting for
patreon
yeah that's a beautiful thing to find
that's a completely different list
it's fascinating i'm just surprised it's
number one like that's not creepy that's
an awesome discovery that's true
there's no vampire baby i gotta say it's
a pretty solid list
it's a very solid list the two doll ones
are a blast i genuinely very very much
hate them are you like someone who's
generally terrified of dolls
oh yeah before we moved back to la we
lived really really close to a doll
museum and we avoided taking that road
at all costs
damn dolls are creepy the vampire doll
one
as creepy as that is i love the one in
the river because
you got like two very definitive things
that could have gone on there
someone probably freaked out and thought
this doll is cursed this doll's haunted
we need to
set it in the put it in the river make
sure no tape it up so no one could find
it or
it's the most hysterical prank in the
world because i mean you find a doll
like that the thing is i could have a
laugh off of going someone's gonna find
this one day and probably freak out but
i wouldn't want to be there you see that
person discovery you know you would need
to
follow it down the river but it didn't
seem like anybody was following it
because you would have seen them
in the background or something so it
leads me to believe
that doll is cursed and caused some
havoc for someone
oh but now they just unleashed the this
curse on these poor people
these unsuspecting humans what are they
gonna do
[ __ ] happens don't just
curse people with dolls that's not a
thing you just
maybe the way to get rid of the curse is
you have to pass the curse along
and then they'll pass the curse along
exactly no
i mean okay you got to do what you got
to do if you had to do that who would
you pass the curse on to
you and dan no questions asked
how dare we live in the same complex
just keep passing it around
until we get to that neighbor we both
mutually hate
i mean yeah and then be like sorry
there's no one else to pass it to
yeah i've i've found one that i had oh
yeah you got one profound of
all right awesome i run into them often
it's not great
what oh yeah you got to tell me that
we're not
exploring with josh what an amazing
video i mean that is
both simultaneously creepy and heroic
at the same time i mean just imagine
like if they had turned back
like a second earlier that kid would
never have been found
i mean that's what i love about slapped
ham's videos is he's really good at
painting the narrative
of the situation of like he's like
pulling videos from other people but
he's really good at like
walking you through it to where you're
experiencing it because like they have
that moment where they're like oh it's
too small they should turn around but
then they decide to go through it hey
it's creepy when you're like what the
hell there's a little girl here
but then it's like wait this little
girl's just lost
and she somehow she landed here and now
you get to be a hero oh my god what a
what a great video what a yeah that
video must've gotten so many views you
son of a [ __ ]
just imagine though being those people
derping around in this cave going oh i
wonder how far this goes and like not
expecting to see
anybody they must have jumped out of
their skin oh yeah
i would have turned around
second i heard a little girl this
haunted get the hell out of here
it's always the little girls that haunt
things
have you noticed that it's rarely little
boys but all these little girls
they have that creepy little hug in like
real life scenarios that yeah that's
what it is it's crazy
because i was expecting to see like who
creepy little girl like oh she's an
innocent
i mean that one in thailand is so funny
what a great prank
you're just tricking silly americans
silly white americans into like what is
this crazy taiwanese creature
like that is so funny there's something
so
poetic about it because imagine like
they were probably
scouring any news had gotten out like
like mainstream
media it'd be like what are these
creatures
yeah they like these people are probably
just laughing their asses off and
they're playing flutes
that's so funny i wish they never came
clean and were like they were actors i
wish that never came out
what i was loved if they just committed
to this a new kind of
cryptid would be being looked
sensation yeah it would have been
awesome and then
decades later they should have revealed
it you gotta have a message
nobody would believe it the same thing
as like the bigfoot
that's what makes it more powerful i
feel like it's
funnier now that we know right after the
fact
definitely it is a prank yeah as opposed
to like the bigfoot where it's like okay
yeah this person said they did it it was
a prank but did they really
it's different because it's not as funny
later yeah no of course
but i don't know i wasn't expecting to
to find something funny when clicking on
this video
bring me the laugh slapped him um but
that first the very first one they
introduced that's a terrifying discovery
oh yeah find a shark just what is that
formaldehyde yep not fluoride
[Laughter]
yeah i mean imagine just stumbling upon
some abandoned building and there's like
a giant shark there
that's so creepy i think just leave it
there though
right like even though they said like it
was already dead and
they brought it over because to preserve
it yeah i get that but that would be
like a great donation to like a natural
history museum or something
it makes me actually suspect of it of
the true intention because it's like
okay maybe the person who called to
the used to owner like oh here's the
story with that shark i'm like are they
covering their ass or
they just abandon the shark there right
because
you think they'd still have legal
requirements to move it down
unless because here's the thing is that
if it's a privately owned zoo i mean
it's in australia
right so like i don't know how
australian law works in that way at
least in the us
i think when you have a privately owned
zoo like you can still own the property
and be liable for whatever on the
property and you're not legally like
obligated to do anything with it so if
somebody still owns the property
they don't have to maybe maybe for it to
be a donation or something like
they have to move it because it's so
large and so heavy it's like thousands
and thousands of pounds that's fair
so it would just be too costly to move
it's a shame
it really is well you know where they
could put that shark in
atlantis oh see what i did loop
the whole video around that's not creepy
this guy's sad but to tell you slap time
i love the hell out of your videos
they're they're some of the best
i mean what's creepy if you discover
atlantis just because the fact that it
was like
under our nose the whole incredible yeah
i mean because here's the thing is like
i love the disney movie oh yes
oh can we talk about it it is
chef's kiss just accurate
best disney best underrated disney movie
of all time i
am fascinated with atlantis like i
almost exclusively watch
atlantis documentaries and like research
films and stuff on the topic because i
love it
i don't know i didn't find it creepy
just because i'm fascinated with the
subject
they were talking about the ruins of
atlantis though right they weren't
talking about
the people of atlantis are still there
no not like finding a
like a tree yeah yeah exactly like we
choose to live away from the rest of
civilization
which would be cool that'd be that
that'd be a little creepy but really
cool at the same time oh did you hear
on the lost civilization you know uh
roanoke and croton
yeah it's been solved no it hasn't it
has
a couple of weeks ago yeah like it's
officially been declared as a
shut case no i don't believe it mm-hmm
this is the government trying to lie to
you
they're trying to it's a government shot
it's never going to be solved no when
you hear about the whole story it's
really stupid and you're going to laugh
no we'll see we'll react to that
i choose not to i i need the legacy to
live on guys subscribe to slapped ham if
you haven't done so already which one of
these creeped you out the most
check out vampire baby doll uh vixx
babydoll what
what's the name of your channel vixen
live vixen vive vixen check out
this on twitch hey last but not least
i love these these are my favorite part
caldorian c
pinnacoos our friend from colorado
hanson native american gentleman i know
things have been
a bit of a slippery slope as of late but
recently you told me
that part of coping with certain moments
in life and just a great way to grow
your brother
is moving in with you your older brother
oh
now with your older brother living with
you you guys can get
drunk together you can get messed up
you could have orgies with your brother
which you know it's weird because some
brothers i feel like are really down for
like that kind of stuff and
then like for me i'm like it's really
never i want that one
yeah exactly so just be mindful of
boundaries when you're participating in
those activities
i'm sorry this is the first part where
my mind went with you and your brother
moving in together
don't touch each other's food that's
very true
good roommate advice right there yeah
trust me i still resent my sister for
taking my food ten years later so
see you know what you're talking about
also don't let your older brother start
up a youtube channel and have him pass
you in subscribers because then
everyone's just going to
make fun of you about that trust me
alyssa knows it's just i can't remember
you do such
different things you know
not really you have you have entirely
different fan bases
yeah you really do i'm like america
england australia big part of mexico as
well
and he's india and you're
native american the best kind
to be because let's face it man anytime
someone's native american even a little
bit of percent you feel like you got
street cred so never forget that
i don't know what that is